did you see the recent recruitment video
of cia i don't know if you caught that
or not have you had a chance to see it
yeah i did i did what do you think about
it
um well there's a lot there's a lot to
uh
to discuss there a i think it's right i
think it's a good idea
for the agency to
try to shine a small light on the
the work of the agency and the intel
community in general
uh and i know that's what they've been
trying to do over the past couple of
years
um and i think that's that's good
um to the degree that they they can and
that it doesn't uh
impact you know sources and methods and
all the rest of it and that's not
something they would do
the ad itself um i think they probably
could have
field tested it a little bit better and
and by that what i mean is
it's a it's it's a much more diverse
work environment than
people give it credit for it's not it's
not
perfect but then again no institution or
business or community in america is
right and they uh and they realize that
and they're always trying
to improve but i think what they should
have done is
taken some of those folks who don't have
cover issues
meaning if you're if you have cover
you're not going to get in one of these
ads
um and and have
various folks within the agency talking
about the challenges
and the excitement and the benefits and
the career paths available
right rather than talking about one
individual walking around and
saying look i i'm not i'm not ticking
boxes but then they proceed to take a
bunch of boxes
um or they talk about it as if it's me
me me
and almost in the by the time they
finish it's almost like what
people been assailing you people been
you know claiming
all these things that you say you're not
like you you didn't earn this you did of
course she earned it she's there right
the agency doesn't you know
that's so let me just play the first 30
seconds if the audience hasn't seen it
just for them to get a glimpse of it
because they're probably
saying what what commercial are we
talking about yeah we're going to play
the first 30 seconds
when i was 17 i quoted zora neale
hurston's how it feels to be colored me
in my college application essay
the line that spoke to me stated simply
i am not tragically colored
there is no sorrow damned up in my soul
nor lurking behind my eyes
i do not mind at all at 17 i had no idea
what life would bring but sora's
sentiment articulated so beautifully
how i felt as a daughter of immigrants
then and now
nothing about me was or is tragic
i am perfectly made i can wax eloquent
on complex legal issues in english
while also belting guayaquil i still
wouldn't think this is a cia commercial
i'm still curious what commercial is
this crying toddler with the other
i'm a woman of color i am a mom i am a
cisgender
still don't know i did not sneak into
cia
now i know now you know is not the
result of a fluke
or slipped through the cracks i earned
my way in
and i earned my way up the ranks of this
organization
i am educated qualified and competent
and sometimes i struggle
i struggle feeling like i could do more
be more to my two sons
and i struggle leaving the office when i
feel there's so much more to do
i used to struggle with imposter
syndrome but at 36
i reflect is this a challenge the cia is
having where they have to make a video
like this to show that they're diverse
and inclusive
no i think this is just a uh this is
just emblematic of the times that we
currently live in right i mean i think
that
i think they're doing the same thing
that you know in a way
that coca-cola did by you know uh
chastising mlb or or you know
uh the all-star game or i i just think
it's
it's sort of a knee-jerk reaction in a
way you know and again not not
denigrating look she's you know full
marks to her she's you know
she's uh in there and she's working and
so she's clearly smart capable all those
things right it just sounds like from
the ad that
like i don't think anybody's walking
around saying she's occupying space
she's not supposed to
or or you know claiming all these things
it just it just sounds
it sounds very defensive and it also
sounds a little bit too messed
right rather than this is a team this is
an organization that works together like
and when it works together
in in in the right fashion it is an
amazing
thing of beauty from an operational
perspective um
it almost looks like the complete
opposite of what jonah mendes talked
about
jonah mendes talked about when you do a
when you become a ci agent it's about
being ambitious driven competitive smart
intellectual
charismatic all this stuff but you don't
need the recognition versus here it's
more like look at me it's about me
look how great again i thought maybe
they're doing this because there's some
internal
challenges going on with the cia where
you know
not enough latinas not not enough women
not enough
african americans but i would assume
that in the cia you almost have to
recruit folks from different
nationalities and ethnicities because
if you're going into different markets
you need to kind of blend in i remember
one time my dad comes up to me
and we have someone in our family that
used to be part of the mi6 and
eventually we found out years later and
it's funny because uh
that person took the same maraud as you
journalistic you know they went through
the media route and a boom they got
picked up sometimes that's
pretty common my dad says hey you you
can tell me
you can tell me i said what's that that
tell me it's okay i i know i already
know at this point i sit down honestly i
swear to god i have no clue what you're
talking about
he says how long have you been with the
cia i said you think i'm with the cia he
says how long have you been with the
city can wink if you are said that i'm
not part of it
if you are it took him five years to
think that his son's probably i'm like
i'm telling you i'm not part of the cia
yeah he uh till today i think he still
has a little bit of uh skepticism
whether i am or not but
anyways i see this here i say i don't
know i don't know if the ad is uh
hey by the way has cia always done
commercials or no have they done
no no no it's i mean it's not the first
one they've done and you know again
they've got a twitter page
and you know and i get why they're doing
it right i just again i just think it's
the wrong
path the wrong marketing message right
have you know she could have simply by
talking about
if she if she had been the same
individual and she had just been walking
through the hallways talking about
the the challenges the benefits of
working for the agency
right you're already sending a message
by having a deliver that but you're
talking about an organizational effort
and a team effort and all those things
so i think the interesting thing about
this this particular ad
is look they pissed off both sides right
they pissed off all the people who are
tired of the
of the wokism and think that it's it's
the wrong path to take and it's dividing
people
and it's also pissed off interestingly
all those cats that did talking about
uh woke ism you know and that are all
woke themselves and because now what
they're complaining about what they're
pissed off about is that
the cia has in their minds usurped their
language right
taken their language of vocalism and
used it for their own benefit so somehow
that's wrong so both sides are irritated
by this
uh you know you could argue that people
are talking about it
uh and if that's your metric you know
for success then hey
fine but it's the cia not pepsi cola so
i don't think that should be the metric
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you